[Música]
con el apoyo del pri y la cámara de
diputados de méxico aprobó ampliar la
permanencia de la guardia nacional en
tareas de seguridad pública hasta 2028
en lugar de 2024 como estaba previsto
uno de los contradictores de la medida
denuncia la militarización paulatina del
país tenemos reportó desde la capital
mexicana
los linenses comenzaron a dar el último
adiós a la reina isabel segunda miles de
personas hacen filas a las afueras del
palacio de westminster donde reposan los
restos de la fallecida monarca durante
cuatro días de cara a su funeral de
estado el 19 de ese tiempo
en ucrania el presidente volodymyr
selenski prometió la victoria ante rusia
al visitar las ciudades de valaquía y
zoom en el noreste del país
ambas retomadas por las fuerzas
ucranianas en medio de la contraofensiva
y tras hablar con la demil footing el
secretario general de la onu dijo que la
posibilidad de un acuerdo de paz sigue
siendo muy lejana
hola y bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
de noticias en francés 24 los saluda
andrés meza muñoz
empezamos en mexico con 335 votos a
favor 152 en contra y una abstención la
cámara de diputados aprobó con mayoría
calificada una reforma constitucional
que permite que el ejército continúe
realizando tareas de seguridad pública
hasta 2028 en lugar de 2024 como estaba
previsto esta medida ha generado
polémica ya que las fuerzas armadas
enfrentan acusaciones de ejecuciones
extrajudiciales desapariciones forzadas
y uso desproporcionado de la fuerza
previamente nuestro corresponsal mario
carbonell nos contaba que implica la
aprobación de esta reforma y que tan
significativo es el apoyo del preso
hola en efecto mira cuando usted creó la
guardia nacional mediante una reforma
constitucional se estableció un artículo
quinto transitorio que facultaba al
presidente para echar mano de las
fuerzas armadas en tareas de seguridad
pública durante cinco años posteriores a
la creación esto mientras se consolidaba
la guardia nacional lo que hoy se está
haciendo es una reforma a ese entramado
jurídico de la constitución para ampliar
ese plazo otros años más hasta 2028 es
decir hasta 2028 podrá haber militares
en las calles patrullando realizando
tareas de seguridad el apoyo del pri fue
fundamental ya que al tratarse de una
reforma constitucional se entera que
habían de dos terceras partes de los
legisladores y sin el pri no hubiera
sido posible esto implica también bueno
implica una fractura en el pri porque
esta reforma pasa ahora a la cámara de
senadores donde los priístas no están de
acuerdo con esta con esta reforma y
también al actuar a la coalición
opositora de los partidos acción
nacional de la revolución democrática y
el siempre que van juntos contra morena
porque porque habían establecido que no
habría reformas a la constitución y
menos en este sentido
en noticias de colombia el ejército de
liberación nacional dijo estar a favor
de un alto el fuego bilateral con el
estado destinado a reanudar las
negociaciones que se suspendieron en
2019 así lo anunció su principal
negociador en cuba' pablo beltrán el
jefe de la delegación del grupo
guerrillero también mencionó que si se
cumplen las condiciones de seguridad
volvería a territorio colombiano durante
las próximas semanas para entablar
conversaciones con sus compañeros en la
selva y afinar su estrategia de cara a
una nueva ronda de negociaciones de las
cuales entre otros venezuela sería
garante
pasamos a reino unido donde continúan
las honras fúnebres de la reina isabel
segunda escoltado por sus hijos el ataúd
fue llevado desde su residencia en
londres el palacio de buckingham hasta
el palacio de westminster sede del
parlamento británico donde permanecerán
sus restos durante cuatro días de cara a
su funeral el 19 de septiembre hasta
allí miles de personas han llegado para
dar el último adiós a la fallecida
monarca se estima que las largas filas
de simpatizantes de la reina isabel 2a
han alcanzado más de 4 kilómetros de
longitud la capilla ardiente se
mantendrá durante 4 días
significa mucho poder despedirme de ella
ver a sus nietos verlas fue algo que
nunca olvidaré nunca lo olvidaré
acabo de ver el fallecimiento de la
reina literalmente ante mis ojos y es
tan triste tan profundo cumplí mi
lealtad hacia ella cuando estuve en la
fuerza aérea durante 22 años así que es
muy triste en noticias de la guerra en
ucrania el presidente volodymyr selenski
visitó las zonas recientemente liberadas
por el ejército ucraniano en el noreste
del país para resaltar los resultados de
la contraofensiva en la región de
jarquín se trata de valaquía edición que
habían sido tomadas por las tropas rusas
donde también pudo presenciar la
devastación provocada por el conflicto
la bandera ucraniana volvió a ondear en
y sium un símbolo de la contraofensiva
de kiev en el noreste y zoom en la
región de heart que es una localidad
estratégica situada dentro del
territorio recuperado por el ejército
ucraniano tras meses bajo control ruso
nuestra ciudad está hablando francamente
a las puertas del donbass la región de
donges empieza a 50 kilómetros de aquí
lo que es el principal objetivo de putin
estábamos casi que resignados a que las
tropas rusas nunca se fueran
tanques marcados con la zeta abandonados
tras la retirada el pasado fin de semana
de miles de tropas rusas la mayor
derrota de moscú desde el mes de abril
cuando los soldados del kremlin se
marcharon de los alrededores de kiev
la vista es muy impactante pero no es
impresionante para mí porque comenzamos
a ver las mismas imágenes de lucha de
los primeros territorios desocupados
entonces es lo mismo edificios
destruidos personas asesinadas
y otro tipo
rusia todavía domina una quinta parte
del territorio ucraniano moscú asegura
que la retirada de la región de jarquín
responde a una estrategia de repliegue
en el donbass mientras tanto en las
zonas liberadas por kiev hay quien
recupera cierta alegría vyacheslav
querido te he estado esperando he estado
esperando sabía que volverías estoy muy
feliz llegué casi a perder la esperanza
pero al final ha vuelto a florecer mamá
sabía que regresaría por ti
sedensky insistió en que ucrania ganará
esta guerra un deseo compartido por la
unión europea que según la presidenta de
la comisión úrsula von der leyen
permanecerá del lado de kiev a pesar de
las represalias energéticas del kremlin
la primera ministra sueca la
socialdemócrata magdalena anderson
anunció que presentará su dimisión al
cargo luego de los resultados de las
elecciones legislativas del domingo con
el 99 7% de los votos escrutados y el
voto exterior ya ha recontado la
oposición de derecha y de extrema
derecha ganó la elección con 176 escaños
frente a los 173 del bloque del gobierno
el partido socialdemócrata siguió siendo
el más votado pero el ultraderechista
demócratas de suecia por el ganador
moral de la jornada al alzarse como
segunda fuerza política del país
armenia y azerbaiyán acordaron un cese
del fuego para poner fin a dos días de
intensos enfrentamientos que han causado
la muerte de unos 155 soldados a ambos
lados los dos países eternos enemigos se
habían acusado mutuamente de instigar
nuevas rondas de bombardeos a través de
sus fronteras
los funerales han comenzado en azerbayán
o un día después de que los
enfrentamientos fronterizos con armenia
mataran a decenas de soldados a ambos
lados los dos países han estado luchando
por la zona montañosa de nagorno karabaj
durante décadas pero esta es la
violencia más mortífera entre los
vecinos desde la pasada guerra de seis
semanas que mató a más de 6500 personas
en 2020 armenia dice que los bombardeos
azerbayanos han obligado al menos dos
mil 750 personas a huir de sus hogares
nos salimos y vimos que ya no era
posible permanecer en nuestras casas que
se estaba produciendo graves bombardeos
estábamos muy asustados huimos de las
casas para evitar quedar atrapados bajo
los extremos
los países exsoviéticos se han
intercambiado las culpas por el
recrudecimiento de las hostilidades
es evidente que esta agresión no fue
planificada con mucha antelación hubo
una larga campaña de propaganda de la
difusión de acusaciones casi
inimaginables de la llamada provocación
militar de armenia las rechazamos
constantemente
armenia ha acusado a azerbayán de ocupar
una parcela de su territorio tomada en
los enfrentamientos del martes y ha
pedido ayuda a su aliado moscú
mientras tanto azerbaiyán ha recibido el
apoyo del pueblo del presidente turco
considerando inaceptable la violación
por parte de armenia del acuerdo
alcanzado tras la guerra de 2020 que se
saldó con la victoria de azerbaiyán
el mundo entero debe saber que como
siempre estamos al lado de nuestros
hermanos azerbaiyanos el mandatario
turco recep tayyip erdogán y su homólogo
ruso vladimir putin hablarán de los
combates cuando se reúnan esta semana el
kremlin ayuda a negociar un acuerdo de
paz entre bakú y ereván hace dos años
pero desde entonces moscú se ha
distraído con su guerra en ucrania que
puede haber provocado un vacío de poder
y ha reavivado la atención hasta que
este informativo en france24 gracias por
acompañarnos continúen con toda nuestra
programación
[Música]